liberal hacks can't quit their attacks
meet the media [ __ ] who want civil
wars they're the hatred spewers who
still can't find viewers
first cnn's don lemon on thursday he
told his 10 remaining viewers
that republicans are doing something
that is very dangerous to society
now two million viewers will see it
roll it jose
republicans are doing something that is
very
dangerous to our society and we have to
acknowledge that we have to acknowledge
that as americans we must acknowledge
that as journalists
because if we don't we're not doing our
jobs we cannot sit here and pretend like
well you republicans it's a cut them a
break let's we want to hear whatever
they have a lot to answer for in this
moment
yeah there's a newsman so much for cnn
being less partisan cnn was supposed to
move to the middle but that move to the
middle lasted about as long as brian
stelter's swearing off corn syrup
he just chugs it down like it's water
not to be outdone msnbc intelligence
analyst malcolm nance
this week rambled on about the sham jan
6 hearings and right-wing extremism in
america and implied that the republican
party has become an insurgency
a year and a half ago when i was calling
this an insurgency people were actually
saying that's crazy well it is and it's
well on its way it's closer to the
beginnings of the irish republican army
uh you know irish republicanism where
now the republican party is shin thing
we will may have to fight
they that they in my title and that they
and might who want to kill americans
are your neighbors
wow so he's openly suggesting
republicans are terrorists that must be
fought because they want to kill you
now if a republican said that they'd be
chastised for incitement or they'd be
liz cheney
and you know facts aren't on his side
when his evidence is a terrorist
organization that lasted decades in
another country
and last this guy is called an
intelligence analyst i mean i know this
is msnbc but this dude's more unbalanced
than a see-saw with jerry nadler
brooke
yes what you what do you make of this
kind of wreck i have so much to say
about that unload please first of all i
wish don lemon would come don lemon
would come out and acknowledge you know
he is not for democracy he doesn't
believe in free and fair elections he
doesn't think people have the right to a
different opinion and he is not an
objective journalist
10 years ago even maybe less if a cnn
anchor came out with this amount of
disdain for you know half of the
american population they would be fired
right away and normally always actually
whatever the left accuses the right of
doing they themselves are guilty of
recall kamala harris fundraising for a
black lives matter bail fund right you
remember when chuck schumer came out and
said brett kavanaugh has to pay the
price and now you have this guy malcolm
nance is his last name by the way he
wrote a book arguing that the way to
counter isis is to empower syria and he
also tweeted when 13 service men and
women were killed in a terrorist attack
in afghanistan he he tweeted
deal with it that's why we're leaving
which he had to apologize
so i'm not taking advice from these
people and i want to end with this the
greatest threat to our democracy is
those who don't believe in free and fair
elections who don't believe in freedom
of assembly who don't believe in free
speech the left presents that threat and
they are open and honest about it and it
is very very scary
cat
let's go back to don lemon
briefly
it should be the name of his career
briefly
do you think he knows his days are
numbered because like that's an open
conflict with what cnn claimed they're
going to do which was to move to the
middle and then he just says like half
the country is a bunch of criminals or a
bad people that you shouldn't
journalists should not
take seriously
either that or he got super drunk the
night before and didn't know what else
to say because he said that a million
times before
like it should be something where we're
like whoa that's that's crazy to say but
it's not because it's crazy how many
times that he keeps saying it
uh it also doesn't help anybody because
like the way that people do become
radicalized when they do
is from nobody else talking to them and
they go deeper and deeper into what they
already believe and then they go even
deeper than that and the conspiracies
and weird stuff
i he he sees himself as a hero for
saying these things but he's not solving
anything and could potentially be making
things worse to think that your average
person who may be voted for trump is a
monster
it's just it's not in line with reality
and that makes it irresponsible even if
it wasn't irresponsible in so many other
ways which it is yeah you know tyrus
neighbors fighting neighbors i'm glad
i'm not your neighbor
no and i kind of wish you were i would
borrow everything
uh a couple things would be fun go in
and just take all the wine
and then
and then you just hear him scream
as he as i shoot it in my backyard he
goes good shot
a couple things uh the brother
nance yeah he said
he said uh common when they first said
this they said i was crazy
my brother we're still saying you're
crazy
i think
you're so right greg and we've both been
fired a time or two
and we have this phrase called going out
in the blaze of glory we just saw his
blaze of glory
he knows his days are numbered so now
he's trying to do what the woke do
because he's the official spokesperson
for that how's that working out and
you double down and then you say things
daring them to fire you because then you
can sue them and so that we can't fire
him he's saying we're gonna fire him and
he's saying that he's alone on the
island he just didn't realize that ever
since people started mourning for things
that doesn't bother them corporations
are now saying you're fired so this is
his blaze of glory he even had the tie
off yes he's not playing around anymore
and he's going after his side and he's
on the losing side and he just he's
daring cnn to do it he's daring them to
do it so and i i wouldn't double dare
them
i have only one comment if uh malcolm
nance and don lemon
are going to be the uh enemy generals
this is going to be the shortest civil
war of all time
[Applause]
i mean what are we going to name the
battles lemons charge
a siege of the santa monica whole foods
natural skin care eye
[Laughter]
all right up next still hillary
persisted to make a show that's easily
resisted
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else